Hillsdale College I hope you all are
enjoying the beautiful weather obviously
it must be global warming of course when
the weather returns to 30 degrees
tomorrow then it will be because of
climate change I tell you it's hard to
keep up with the terminology it's a good
thing that I'm taking the CCA my name is
Brandon butts
I'm a senior pursuing a marketing
management major I'm team captain of the
forensics competitive speech team and a
member of Delta Tau Delta fraternity
here on campus it is my honor and
privilege to introduce dr. Kenneth P
green to our campus today Kenneth B
green is senior director of the Center
for natural resources at the Fraser
Institute dr. green earned a bachelor's
degree in biology from UCLA a master's
degree in molecular genetics from San
Diego State University and a PhD in
environmental science and engineering
from UCLA he has studied environmental
energy and natural resource policy at
several think-tanks including The Reason
Foundation and the American Enterprise
Institute dr. Greene is testified before
several state and federal legislative
bodies in the United States including
committees and subcommittees of the
House of Representatives and the Senate
he twice reviewed reports for the United
Nations Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change he is the author of two
textbooks global warming understanding
the debate and abundant energy the
abundant energy the fuel of human
flourishing please help me welcome dr.
Kenneth B green
well thank you all for for being here
this afternoon let me bring my notes
back up
I hope I'm paperless so again thank you
for being here all the more it's a
pleasure to to be down here from Calgary
and Alberta all the more so because it
was minus 15 degrees centigrade today
and I get to miss some of the worst of
the the current polar blast polar vortex
that's going through but my consolation
is we have a conservative prime minister
and you don't so yeah yeah yeah I'd like
to thank hillside Hill Hill the
Hillsdale College particularly Matt Bell
for inviting me to speak to you today to
offering up such a spectacular podium
great venue and it's such an esteemed
list of fellow speakers who unfortunate
I won't get to see all of them because I
don't have enough time to stay but I
know you're going to be educated
infuriated and entertained by the
speakers in the next couple of the next
day I also wanna compliment hills that
was a lovely campus the facility said I
said are beautiful I was gonna take a
selfie of myself with Ronald Reagan out
in the quad and and I realized that
Ronald Reagan was rightfully so larger
than life and that if I did take a
picture with him I'd look a bit like a
dwarf and and then it occurred to me to
ask maybe they did that on purpose to
discourage people from taking
disrespectful selfies does it make you
look small
if so very smart today's lunch speaker
was a hard act to follow
particularly his his PowerPoint deck and
his bank account but I'm glad I'm going
where I am because you're at your
evening speakers Steve Hayward who's
back there in the audience somewhere
well in doubtlessly put me to shame when
he gives his presentation I won't be
using as PowerPoint today by the way as
the saying goes absolute power corrupts
and PowerPoint corrupts absolutely
so today we're going to we're going to
talk about like think of as an actually
iconic example of how an environmental
policy can go totally wrong the policy
which we refer to as the ethanol mandate
is the legal requirement that you mix
ethanol into your gasoline the gasoline
you put in your cars at ten percent at a
ten percent level right now so first
we'll start with a little bit of
background information on gasoline and
ethanol then we'll get to politics if I
get to it too far into the weeds feel
free to interrupt if I can hear you from
back in the end the other side of the
football field so gasoline you know as
you know is just a component of oil
it's that lovely black stuff that
squirts out of the ground and turns into
money to be specific gasoline is a blend
of lightweight hydrocarbons that's
chains made of hydrogen and carbon that
range from four to twelve carbon atoms
that is they're very light they're the
lightest components some of the lightest
components of oil you isolate gasoline
or petrol as we call it up north where
we unfortunately tax it much more highly
than you do from oil you get a from oil
through a process called fractional
distillation which we'll talk about a
little bit but not much for gasoline
that happens in refinery and the the
joyful thing about about oil is that
contains within itself all the energy
needed to break it apart into the
amazing of the useful things we get like
gasoline aviation gas diesel plastics
fertilizers etc ethanol as you probably
know how many people know what ethanol
is very good we have a highly educated
how many of you consume it on a regular
basis how many of you consume too much
of it on a regular basis so ethanol as
you probably know is type of alcohol
it's the stuff that gets you potted
other types of alcohol you've probably
heard of our methanol isopropyl alcohol
those won't get you potted however they
might get you planted if you consume
them because they're there they're toxic
alcohol is also a carbon chain but it's
got a specific chemical group attached
to it that makes it an alcohol we don't
need
you all remember your advanced
biochemistry from college
you all remember your biochemistry so
ethanol is made from sure and to be cose
to be specific the stuff that plants
make when you expose them to sunlight
and give them sufficient water you can
get sugar from many different plants it
makes for the four basic booze groups
sugar cane of course gives us rum but
that the potatoes in wheat give us vodka
rice give us a sake barley gives us beer
the staff of life grapes give us wine in
corn we get moonshine basically starch
any kind of starch is just composed of
sugar molecules you can break it down to
feed it to yeast and we make them they
generate beer they raise the raise your
bread loving your bread they ferment
your cheese's we also get things like
antibiotics from yeast and for that
matter we east infections from yeast but
that's for another class anyway to make
ethanol you feed sugar to yeast in a
liquid solution the little critters go
through a process called fermentation
they create the alcohol molecules and lo
and behold it starts to build up in the
solution until it's a high of 20% or so
it starts to kill the little yeast ES
and they stop making it not surprisingly
at that point you fermentation usually
stops even lower than that and at that
point you have faced the challenge now
of getting the ethanol out of the
mixture of water right so what you do is
you distill it that is you heat the
solution up just to the point where the
alcohol comes off in steam and the water
stays behind and you do that repeatedly
you cool the steam down into a liquid
you run it through over and over again
if you really want it pure there's
another chemical step and voila you have
purified ethanol so we should note in
this chemistry lesson is almost almost
over
we should note at this point that
there's a big difference between ethanol
and gasoline right gasoline came to us
because we just took a fraction off of
an interview rich substance for a fuel
we had to actually make the ethanol with
an input of energy so that we could then
consume its fuel it's it's it's energy
content in another way and that actually
was the was the first argument being
made against ethanol by people who were
of an engineering mentality that it's it
takes more energy in than it then it
gets out and it's it see it's it's an
interesting but not terribly useful
argument against ethanol and that's why
we wound up stuck with the ethanol
mandate is because in this case if you
want a liquid fuel you are willing to
pay more for that fuel in terms of
energy input if the other kind of fuel
that you're using isn't suitable for
your task right so if I really want to
liquid fuel and all I have is coal it
doesn't matter that I have to invest
take more of the energy from coal to
make a less energy in the ethanol
because I want a liquid fuel and so it's
not really a good argument it's true but
it's not a good argument it's the same
pretty much of everything we use as a
matter of fact if I want aluminum pure
aluminum I don't really care if the
energy left in the bonds of the of the
metal atoms is more than the humungous
amount of energy it took for me to mine
process and make the aluminum in the
first place because there wasn't much I
was going to be able to I can't wrap my
food in bauxite right I can't wrap my
food in Lumina foil so I don't really
care very much about that so enough with
the chemistry let's get to the policy
how did we get here well the ethanol
story and Matt where are ya can you give
me a time marker when you're okay give
me a time marker if we get if we get off
cycle here the ethanol story is a pretty
long one
in fact ethanol in turpentine were used
to power internal combustion engines all
the way back in 1826 it was also a
component of lamp fuel in the 1850s and
in 1908 Henry Ford's model-t was was
amazingly enough a flex-fuel vehicle
that could run on either a
or gasoline the advantage of simple s
much simpler engineering for various
reasons including lots of cheap oil
ethanol lost out t a saline as the motor
fuel of choice and then the QA we can
discuss this but it's a very similar
reason to why electric cars lost out to
gasoline is because they just couldn't
match the performance and the energy
density of gasoline which is of lecture
the seminar I could give all by itself
because it's it's wonderful stuff if it
didn't exist we'd have to have his end
in it and that's where things stood
ethanol was a niche use until our
friends in OPEC shook things up in the
1973 oil embargo exposing Americans to
too long gas lines and high prices I
should tell you that at that point I
could have been one of the country's
first ethanol moguls after pushing the
car family car into the gas lines for
enough enough times I was already a geek
when I was a young man and so I I got
interested in this popular science and
Popular Mechanics started putting out
articles about run your car on ethanol
right and I thought hey that's a great
idea I was living in California at the
time in the San Fernando Valley which is
a giant orange grove really and they
have every year they have a humongous
amount of oranges that just basically
get rounded up and thrown in the
landfill and I thought hey you know if I
could gather some of those up I could
ferment them distill some ethanol and we
could spike the gas in our and in the
family car with it with the ethanol and
maybe even some France sells some of the
friends and I could have been a mogul
but even that even had still designs
that were solar to talk about how
environmentally forward-looking I was I
had so solar still designs that I had
ordered ordered through popular science
but the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms was not amused that the idea of
a 13 year old boy distilling alcohol in
his backyard and so the experiments I'm
afraid didn't go for it very far forward
ethanol took off as a fuel after Richard
Nixon who you thought you already had
reasons to hate made it a goal for the
United States to get off of foreign oil
and starting around 1978 Congress
started creating incentives for the
production of ethanol to be mixed
the gas in the gas supply and we've been
stuck with the stuff in greater and
lesser quantities ever since a parallel
driver of the ethanol ethanol fuel craze
was California regulators they needed to
add some new gasoline in the winter time
to bring carbon monoxide levels down in
your car they start first started going
with a chemical called MTBE which was a
byproduct
turns out MTBE is so slippery that when
you put it in tanks you might as well be
putting it in the sieve and so they
contaminated virtually every gas station
in California with MTBE so they switched
them to an alternative which was ethanol
and that created the modern ethanol fuel
industry so the drivers were political
the industry was created the existed in
California that could be exploited and
it was they gotta make ethanol I got the
biggest boost really big boost when
George W Bush who famously abstained
from drinking this stuff maybe this was
this was part of the problem expressed
the fondness for ethanol fuel in his
2006 energy speech the first time I
think in history that a president ever
discussed switchgrass which he followed
up by signing the Renewable Fuels
standard in 2007 it called for the US
use 36 billion gallons of biofuels by
2022 with 15 millions consisting of
conventional corn ethanol and 21 billion
gallons consisting of advanced biofuels
such as ethanol made from different
materials other than food woody
materials that are non-food woody
materials and grasses we'll talk about
that in a bit so but if anything
happened on the way to our happy ethanol
future over the years it's become clear
that ethanol poses a lot of
environmental problems one of the most
serious ones is overuse and destruction
of land and water according to a couple
of scientists in science magazine we're
finding this a gallon of corn ethanol
requires 35 gallons of water but that's
just the refining when you talk when you
add up what it's needed to grow the corn
because a lot of corn in the United
States is irrigated it turns out to be a
hunt and if you just look at the corn
specifically destined to be a fuel
it takes 140 gallons of water to make a
gallon of ethanol that's produced now
he's probably heard last night
environmentalists are screaming about
the water consumption used in fracking
but they've always been curiously silent
about the water use consumed in making
fuel ethanol which they promoted as a
carbon neutral fuel in addition to
overusing water ethanol production also
pollutes the water that we have in a
research from the National Research
Council they pointed out that corn
ethanol more corn ethanol for more corn
for ethanol means more fertilizers more
pesticides and more herbicides hitting
the waterways more low oxygen dead zones
off the coasts more fertilizer runoff
off the coasts and in by using bass and
more local shortages in water for
drinking and irrigation it also creates
far-reaching problems in the places like
the Gulf of Mexico and the Chesapeake
Bay where fertilizer runs off microbes
in the water consume it they also
consume all the oxygen and that creates
giant dead zones where there's not
enough oxygen for fish or shellfish to
survive and the more ethanol we make the
more that that that pollution gets worse
it also consumes a lot of land and a
science article from 2008 researchers
calculated that producing the 15 billion
gallons of corn ethanol to meet the u.s.
goals would require the diversion of
corn from 12 million hectares of u.s.
cropland which would in turn bring 11
million hectares of additional land into
cultivation those locations Brazil the
rainforests 2.3 million acres in China
and India 2.2 million new acres brought
under cultivation here in the United
States so if you like land being used
for something other than just living on
in agriculture you have to conclude that
ethanol was it was a bad bargain with
regard to protecting the environment
curious enough when you add ethanol to
your fuel it actually creates more
conventional pollutants and who said
that your US EPA in 1997 they admitted
that adding ethanol to the gasoline
more nitrous oxides more greenhouse
gases than regular gasoline and
particularly methane and carbon dioxide
the findings were Val have been
validated since especially with regard
to greenhouse gases turns out when you
level land for cultivation the initial
release of greenhouse gases is so large
that it takes over 30 years to to what
you have twice the greenhouse gas
emissions if you looked at it over a 30
year time line then if you had just gone
with gasoline and it's over a hundred
and sixty-seven years before you really
cancel out the initial pulse of gases
you put up with a smaller amount you
generate when you use the ethanol
nationwide I can go on with some
statistics but it creates more volatile
organic carbon compounds that's the
stuff you see as haze it makes more
nitrous oxides which lead to ozone
formation and so forth so so on all
fronts environmental it's a very bad
deal well what about claims it will
bring down gasoline prices by
substituting oil gasoline from expensive
and always peaking oil I was on the
radio the other day and my opponent said
you know we know that oil prices were
only going to go up and I said have you
looked at the oil price lately but
that's another story
peak oil again we can we could spend an
hour on peak oil so if you actually look
at what happens with gasoline it turns
out that and those are us who understand
markets and know this intuitively right
which is if I'm gonna sell you ethanol
and I'm a private producer I'm gonna
sell it to you at the same price as
you'd pay for an equivalent amount of
gasoline I'm gonna sell it to you for
the same energy content you'd get from
gasoline which means I'll sell it to you
for about 67 percent of the price of
current gasoline because you need 67%
that you only get 67% of the energy out
of a gallon so I saw you a gallon on my
ethanol at 2/3 the price gasoline since
that'll take you 2/3 as far and so when
people have looked at the price on of
gasoline in the United States it is not
brought down
by ethanol well but somebody will say
well but that's only the first
generation of biofuels to which I would
reply having started in 1908 it's a very
long generation it might be the longest
generation it's the only older orphan or
infant infant energy sector that I can
think of is wind which of course has
been around since the time of sailing
ships but so though it's a can the
second generation is gonna be made from
cellulose which is the woody stems of
corn or grasses or trees or this podium
or the shells of shrimp or the shells of
insects it's gonna be made from
cellulose and therefore it won't have
any of these nasty effects that you're
talking about and it's they mandated
that we're gonna use a lot of the
cellulosic ethanol in the EPA there's
only one small problem with it which is
first of all if it uses any kind of crop
at all
corn stems are the same as the corn the
ears all of the land and growth problems
are the same you still have to water the
corn to get the stem or the stalk you
still have to water the grass is to get
the grasses and you still have to use
spend huge amounts of energy
concentrating woody pulpy material to
get it into and turn it into fuel you
also have to use great deals or energy
to crack thus the cellulose apart the
reason its cellulose is evolutionarily a
very tough material it's the it's the in
case you've forgotten cellulose is the
material that is in the wall cell walls
of plants that allow trees to grow up
and not flop over right so it tells you
how it's a very difficult material to
break down and so it turns out you have
to if you're trying to break it down you
wind up putting even more energy into
your ethanol creating more greenhouse
gases and creating more conventional
pollutants but more importantly it's
extremely expensive to make
no one has successfully made it
commercially which takes us to the very
interesting phenomenon in which the
companies were fined by the Treasury
because they failed they were fined
about seven million dollars in penalties
for failing to mix cellulosic ethanol a
fuel that didn't exist
into gasoline they recently finally got
out from under that particular penalty
it's uh and here's the worst part if and
this is so common of environmental
policies which is they're promulgated by
relatively wealthy city dwellers and
they almost invariably hurt poor people
in rural people ethanol raises the price
of food because it diverts corn from the
food supply that would be fed to animals
and as it commands a higher price as
ethanol subsidized ethanol it means that
corn prices rise and that means animal
feed prices rise and that means if your
your poultry and your beef and
everything else go up with it if you've
looked at the prices of beef lately
you'll know it's well and it's well
untrue the US projections are by 2016
the US will have diverted 43 percent of
its cropland
just to produce ethanol fuel almost half
the interesting statistic because in the
past actually before cars the US had
half of its farmland was devoted just to
growing hay for horses which is
considerably more benign actually
activity food prices went up and around
the world because of ethanol there were
nearly riots in Mexico over the price of
tortillas at the peak when met when then
when the new ethanol mandates came in
the World Trade Organization the Food
and Agriculture Organization of the
United Nations the International Fund
for agricultural development the
International Monetary Fund and the OECD
the United States conference on Trade
and Development the World Food Program
the International Food Policy Research
Institute un high-level Task Force on
this and at the World Bank all concluded
the same thing the use of ethanol in
fuel raises food prices and harms the
poor wages disproportionately harms the
poor the head of the FAO Food and
Agriculture Organization has called for
the termination of biofuel use and so
have other some even some environmental
organizations have finally figured this
out and have gently backed away from
supporting ethanol and when I mentioned
biofuels I should just I should throw in
a quick caveat and and
I'm gonna have plenty time for Q&A
anytime the basic logic of this is
simple if you put a bounty or a price on
a square on an acre of land that is
higher than its comparative uses whether
it's forest
whether it's wilderness area whether
it's campgrounds whether it's existing
crops you know how markets work right
more land will be planted under that
artificially subsidized crop at the
expense of anything and this is
particularly true in developing
countries where they don't have good
good environmental protections and land
set aside is that the very places that
the environmentalist are saying these
are the lungs of the planet are being
cut down to make biofuels to sell into
the European and American markets even
and this is a miracle
so hallelujah even Dianne Feinstein
sponsored a bill to end the ethanol
mandate the bill was killed as
everything has gone in in the great
legislative graveyard graveyard of the
Senate but there are still some other
reform efforts but the final lesson of
the of the ethanol story the real story
of ethanol is this once you build an
industry that depends on subsidies and
fuel mandates to make its profit they
learn the levers of power really really
fast and they learn how to buy
themselves influence to maintain the
flow of fuel to their particular bank
accounts and for years now if ten
probably well over 10 15 years we've
known this was a very bad deal but the
industry ethanol industry has shown it's
it's easy very easy to get a pig to a
trot it's not so easy to get them away
from it
with that we have lots of time for
questions we can discuss everything you
want to is as when I was introduced to
you know I've written about climate
change I've written about most of these
things for quite a long time so now fair
game on almost anything you want to talk
about including Canada the True North
strong and free
and our hockey teams go flames go thank
you
good got a lot of time for questions
great so we have time for question we
have two microphones here please raise
your hand and stand when they get to you
and they will hold the microphone for
you
that's smart good policy - all is about
35% oxygen and hydrocarbons basically
zero and since it was used in California
to complete the combustion process from
carbon monoxide to carbon dioxide is
there some value for a certain amount of
ethanol in gasoline but probably well
below 10% what one can argue that if
you're in an area like Los Angeles was
where you have essentially a giant Basin
or a bowl that concentrates your
pollutant levels especially in the
wintertime when the air pressure comes
down the air the height of the
atmosphere comes down because the air is
cold you you do want to suppress the
production of carbon monoxide whether
adding ethanol to your fuel is the best
way to do it is the different questions
an open question I would say there was
utility in it at the time because the
the carbon monoxide levels carbon
monoxide is the stuff that actually
kills you or it used to it's why you'd
run your car in your garage with your
garage closed because the carbon
monoxide would bill to be kill you now
curious enough car emission systems are
so good that you could you can't kill
yourself that way anymore
you could suffocate yourself from a lack
of oxygen if you stayed there long
enough but you couldn't the carbon
monoxide won't kill you but yeah it does
make a certain amount of sense to to
knock that down the levels in Los
Angeles when they first started using it
were quite high in the wintertime they
were high enough that in theory some
people's health was being compromised
particularly children carbon monoxide is
a chemical that binds to your red blood
cells and prevents them from taking
oxygen to your body to your to your
brain and particularly in young children
they the development doesn't really it's
not
good for development with the evidence
at time suggested it wasn't good for
doing so yeah I think there's probably
some niche applicability now I think the
the the catalytic converter technology
this point has gotten so good and the
computerized fuel mixtures are so good
you probably wouldn't want to do it with
ethanol but that again that's that's the
that's the unintended consequence when
you create an industry is its
self-sustaining and it tends to prevent
alternative solution pathways Cuba is
known for its ability to grow sugar cane
sugar cane is seven times more efficient
for ethanol production than is corn
why is Cuba not turning away from sugar
production from producing ethanol
well they and Brazil makes a large
amount of money on on sugar cane ethanol
as well sugar cane is much more
efficient as a feedstock to make ethanol
and in Brazil where essentially they use
the equivalent of slave labor to harvest
it the problem with sugar cane is that
it's extremely laborious to harvest and
so you want the highest price use for
the sugar that you can use and in some
cases sugar subsidies and things like
that mean you get more for the sugar and
less for the ethanol and it turns out
that that Brazil actually when you look
at Brazil's economic development even
though they largely an ethanol fueled
system for their cars most of their
income over the last twenty years has
been from oil exports so the sugarcane
would be a better better crop and and
some places that have lots and lots of
sugarcane and have no liquid fuels again
you know okay something like Hawaii
right you have lots and lots of access
to sugarcane you used to and you don't
have a lot of oil access or gasoline
access so there are places it makes
sense to go with sugarcane it has all
very similar environmental impacts a
little less so than corn but so yeah you
can use you can use okay and
unfortunately
I don't know how well sugarcane grows in
this environment boy in Kansas where
every politician goes to have an ethanol
epiphany and and decide they love
ethanol so there are limited places
where you can grow sugar cane and and
have the manual laborers with machetes
to harvest it really cheaply we have
lots of questions thank you so much for
your time today
my question is going to lend into the
work that you've done with the United
Nations specifically the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change now some would argue post
Climategate email scandals that the IPCC
has undertaken a certain agenda rather
than actual science now how does the
IPCC's advocacy if there is advocacy
actually play into the ethanol debate
that modern America has today thank you
sir sure yeah the IPCC I reviewed the
for the record this the science volume
of the of the the third assessment
report and it's entirely and that was a
masochistic ritual that I engaged in
when I decided that was gonna start
working on the subject I decided that
would read the the giant omnibus reports
that they put out that define our
current understanding of the science and
no good deed goes unpunished so I was
then asked to review a special report on
aviation and the global climate that one
was actually kind of fun because the
chemistry is really obscure of what
happens when a plane goes up in the air
and and puts out emissions and it's not
as if you can stick a muffler on the
back of them so the way it plays it
plays out is and the IPCC's an
interesting creature is it has gotten
steadily more politicized over time if
you read the orginal first Assessment
Report nobody read it and therefore it
wasn't the big political football quite
cautious in its in its conclusions in
fact the first assessment report didn't
come to a conclusion that humans were
having a predominant effect on the
climate the second assessment report
when things got a little more political
started to have somewhat a more
aggressive statements but again the
actual technical reports were pretty
good in terms of saying well you know if
you double co2 levels in the atmosphere
you could see a range of warming from
one and a half degrees C to four and a
half degrees C we don't have any idea
what it's going to be
and you know and so that was pretty good
the third assessment report which I
reviewed was also good although this is
when they started to play some games
because they started to assign
confidence levels to what they were
saying because it they didn't think
people were being scared badly enough so
they needed some new adjectives and so
they created a ranking system for how
confident the scientists were in what
they were what they were doing and they
used them it was kind of a musical I
this was one of my comments to their the
drafts which is as they put it they used
a an informal Bayesian meta analysis of
their findings to determine whether or
not they were confident in them and I
looked into what that meant and what it
basically means is they asked the
researchers who write the report
themselves if they believed what they
wrote alright I kid you not I kid you
not the researchers who write the
reports have a little checkbox that says
I'm very confident in my while I just
wrote and they've progressively refined
and hidden that and the subsequent
reports they've gotten very good at
doing something at making the reports
the actual scientific reports completely
unquote able so nearly every sentence is
a paragraph long and it's got 15 of
these we have low confidence to medium
confidence in our in this statin the
other thing so they've largely become
uncodable against the UN and then and
more even more recently they just
released a report called the synthesis
report that draws us together these
books and came up with a 40 page policy
guide for summary guys for policy makers
those are rarely in any way balanced by
the science and the underlying reports
how it plays out the ethanol debate here
some people still believe that
greenhouse gas emissions have to be
controlled ethanol is seen as a carbon
neutral fuel because you can't capture
the carbon out of the air what in in
your corn you burn it you release the
carbon again and the cycle continues
kumbaya and so as a quote carbon neutral
fuel that's where the pressure comes
from for ethanol in the u.s. context
today and all biofuels soy bean based
biodiesel
you need jatropha biodiesel you name it
there is one technical one technology
I'm cautiously optimistic about for
creating a biofuel but that's algae
that's a subject for a different
different day
tell us a little bit about the subsidies
past president future for ethanol well
there used to be more some of the
subsidies have actually been reduced
there were there were subsidies to
farmers to grow the corn and there were
subsidies to the ethanol manufacturers
to produce the ethanol they have phased
out the farm subsidy I believe they're
still tapering down that the the
manufacturers subsidy but I haven't
looked at this in a couple years the
bigger problem is the mandate itself is
a subsidy right when you when you
require when I require that you blend in
X percent of decaf into your coffee
right
I've now guaranteed you forced you to
buy the product at the same price of
coffee and so the meant the existence of
the mandate itself is the primary is the
biggest subsidy but they had also about
80 cents worth of subsidies directly 80
cents a gallon to produce it in the
beginning that's where we got this
that's where the the the industry came
from is essentially they were they were
built up on subsidies lots of questions
in the front all right you back people
what are you doing back there that's why
we're sitting in the front yeah I guess
that's it for the largest producers of
ethanol used in the United States and
which of our politicians our deepest in
the darkest corners of their pockets
that's an interesting question a lot of
ethanol is produced by offshoots of oil
companies in the States but I can't tell
you who specifically the largest
producer of ethanol Oh Steve you have an
idea oh yeah well the by far the largest
beneficiary of the whole thing would be
our trijet Archer Daniels Midland the
people who used to do those cook those
lovely commercials on Saturday Sunday
afternoon and news programs opinion
programs but as for the politicians this
is an equal opportunity Despoiler right
so on the eve of running for president I
think Bob Dole had a conversion in Iowa
about corn ethanol what's his name
McCain who had run against
and all fuel on the eve of campaigning
in Iowa change changed his mind suddenly
something about crossing the border into
Iowa
it doesn't seem no matter what party
affiliation you are at you cross the I
on Iowa ethanol derangement line and and
pretty soon you're for it
but you know the these lobby groups know
the math of America which is you can
stop legislation if you get one by one
senator or you know ten Congress people
and if you're gonna lose ten billion
dollars it's worth you throwing two
billion to keep it and so that's the
that's the the built-in problem of
American politics I have to two
questions Oh gonna strain my memory here
first question is if Congress mandates
catalytic converters and catalytic
converters convert unburned hydrocarbons
in the co2 is it the official policy of
Congress that co2 is benign and why is
the EPA regulating it the second
question is is if ethanol is driving the
price of corn and has resulted in the
reduction of animal herds and it driven
up driven up the price of beef what
accounts for the extremely low prices of
corn right now on the market so the
first question is this Congress think
co2 is benign I would I would argue it's
actually more a matter of the left hand
not knowing what the right hand is doing
and deciding that they'd rather have
perfectly combusted they probably did
first of all okay well assuming that
Congress understands what it means to
have perfectly combustive gasoline is
itself a stretch but they probably
assume that it's the lesser of two evils
right if you complete the combustion you
do have some more co2 but you have less
carbon dioxide less volatile organic
carbon compounds less nitrous oxides and
s less sulfur oxides less particulate
matter etc and so you might decide that
the lesser of two evils because co2 is
non-toxic
and this was done before the use of
ethanol for those purposes was done
before the greenhouse gases were driving
all you know practically all US policy
why is corn down now partly it's because
gasoline is down and oil is down right
so you're basically gonna follow the
price market at this point for what they
can get for the fuel that's blended in
plus EPA plus they and they have I think
I believe backed off on the this the the
demand for cellulosic or for non
conventional forms and they reach their
cap that's the other thing is they're
making as much ethanol as they can there
at the they're at the conventional
ethanol cap of 15 billion gallons and so
they're no longer driving up it's not
driving food prices higher corn prices
higher and they've been so good at
putting so much more corn or land under
corn that you now have a lot more corn
we have at the moment to kind of
contradictory policies in the federal
government level we have that well much
more than two but specifically with the
topic of ethanol you have not only the
RFS with its 15 billion gallon mandate
but you also have the federal government
policy that requires automobile
manufacturers to have their conflicts
operating it at a much higher level of
fuel efficiency as we progress into the
century ethanol granted has a lower
efficiency than gasoline and so it's
actually less miles per gallon how does
the federal government plan or do they
even realize the problem that they're
that they're under of saying we want
higher and better fuel efficiency and at
the same time we also want to put
ethanol which is worse fuel efficiency
in other words what gives in my in my
experience government spends remarkably
little time considering whether or not
there internally consistent in fact I
suspect if they did it would be a very
beneficial thing because they most of
their heads would explode and and we'd
get a smarter crop of evil politicians
but no I think I think that the they
don't care again the agenda on fuel
economy is to knock down co2 emissions
and so if they consider it that's the
be-all and end-all of vehicle fuel
economy standards and and regulations to
the extent that you get a value or a
bargain out of it they could care less
and so they don't care it's that it
doesn't strike them as a contradiction
to make you put two simultaneously
increase and decrease your vehicle's
fuel economy with different mandates
that it's the the net product at the end
is doesn't reduce greenhouse gas
emissions or not and if it does then
let's pass it regardless of whether it
makes your car an extra ten thousand
dollars in price prevents people from
getting into their car into the car
market slows the overall industry down
and create other knock-on effects there
it's a single value judgement this
gentleman here one here and one over
there so what it could the could ethanol
be more effective or inefficient if they
basically used waste you were talking
about the oranges or if they just used
corn stalks when the corn was already
being used for something else you think
that if they use stuff that was already
going to waste that could possibly make
ethanol more more of a viable
opportunity there's two arguments on
there's two arguments for that which is
if you really limited yourself only be
using the waste product from corn that
was going into the food market you could
make a good argument for that but right
now we plow that it you a lot of the
times that's plowed back into the soil
right to keep the soil organic content
up so what you're going to be doing is
is you're going to be steadily depleting
the soil and then having to add yet more
fertilizer in to account for the fact
that you've taken all the organic matter
out of the soil and so you want end up
chasing your tail over time plus the
corn stalks again the problem with corn
stalks is that the reason they're strong
enough to hold up these gorgeous heads
of corn we get is because the cellulose
of the plant walls is thick and highly
resistant to being broken down
you have to use they use a steam process
and then enzymes which are quite
expensive to try to break down cellulose
into sugar so that it can then be made
into in death all usually waste crops I
mean is its it again there's a good idea
if you can do it economically and
compete or if you live in a place where
you you pay a huge premium for gas
premiums or no pun intended
you pay a huge premium for premium you
might want to go that way and then race
cars have been powered by methanol for a
long time
methanol is another option but really
very little beats beats gasoline because
as Robert Bryce will probably will tell
you he'll probably give the lecture on
fuel density but when you think about
the power I'll beat him to the punch
which is when you think about the power
embedded in gasoline or and oil it's
simply higher by any standard than
comparable liquid fuel it comparable
fuels so you know imagine a cup of
ground wood pellets and how much of a
fire that would make how much food you
could cook on that imagine a cup full of
coal and how much you might be able to
cook on that imagine a cup full of
gasoline and if you'd ripped it out onto
a pan and let it burn you could cook a
lot more on that and then what I tell
students is now imagine a cup of wind or
a cup of sunlight and you understand
energy density right away and so it just
doesn't generally compete but I it was
almost an entrepreneur hi so correct me
if I'm wrong on this timeline Bush gave
his speech in 2007 or 2006 six I'm
talking about ethanol and how it's a
politically ridden kind of had some sort
of political motive there maybe just
talking about it because he was a
politician but the I've heard that there
is an initial surge or a secondary surge
an investment in ethanol in 2005 around
then is that right okay so wouldn't that
have meant that there was and I've heard
that the investment surge was based on
the success of ethanol around 2005
is that right as well well the
investment wave was because you already
had the requirement for conventional
ethanol to go from where it was then up
to it's 15 billion barrel cap right and
so with the government mandate in place
money flows if I if I put a mandate in
place guarantee you a certain rate of
return I have my farm subsidies I lined
up I have my subsidy so the ethanol
manufacturers lined up
I threw a whole bunch of money into
engineering schools to figure out how to
lower the costs of refining of producing
ethanol just fermenting and distilling
so you'd see that surge anyway but it
wasn't related to the timing of the
announcement on the cellulosic other
than to say that they wanted to increase
the standard because of perceived energy
insecurity the Bush administration was a
big big on energy security and they
perceived having a more domestic supply
of liquid fuels would be good and they
were just they bought the con of
cellulosic ethanol that they were being
told by their scientists that it was
ready for prime time and etcetera
etcetera etc and of course it was
nowhere near ready for any kind of
deployment and still it still is not not
ready for deployment and I'm yes I would
be I would predict it will not be ready
for deployment for decades and barring
barring a technological breakthrough
don't leak incentive there we go
it's my understanding that ethanol
decreases the energy and gasoline by 30%
my next question is that before the
Industrial Age co2 in the atmosphere was
roughly 280 parts per million it's now
up to 380 parts per million this is
increased the fertilizing effect of co2
by roughly 3% on all across mm-hmm
what's wrong with this from my
perspective very little I mean I think
we you know for the for the official
record since otherwise to differ with
the the revealed knowledge makes one a
denier I'll simply state that you know
I'm a climate acceptor I know how co2
works in the atmosphere and that if you
increase the concentration you should
trap some heat somewhere a little bit
how much is the open question whether
it's a tiny amount or a larger amount -
and my answer is there's two ways to
figure that out well you can go to a
giant climate model computer model of
the climate which is like a bit like a
computerized horoscope lots of
predictions you can go to that and you
can plug your addiction your assumptions
in and you can crank your little lever
and get any number out you want or you
can actually look at what has happened
to temperatures while greenhouse gas
emissions have gone up since the
Industrial Revolution if you do that you
find a very mild rate of warming
probably one degrees around one degree
centigrade we use the metric system one
degree centigrade per doubling of co2 in
the atmosphere that to me is not a major
crisis nor would trying to stop it be
less damaging than the than the
projected damage to those few areas
where they're extremely low lying or
even almost under sea level and or they
have huge prolonged droughts that could
be made worse by a couple of tenths of a
degree in the temperature increase but
many people have pointed out to pointed
out the fertilizing effect of
of co2 on plant life the planet is
greener by far and but part of that also
is policies we have where we've set
aside huge amounts of area for
reforestation as well as the
establishment of a giant wood industry
so I don't find it a problem but the
politicians aren't the problem that
makes it my problem makes it all our
problem someone asked about the price of
corn being depressed but and and and you
answered that part of is because the
ethanol cap was reached with a what the
market can absorb it at ten percent of
what is the consumption of the gallons
of gasoline but has there not been a
greater effect brought on by an over
supply of corn we've had record harvest
in largely because the climate in the
Corn Belt sea States was very favorable
this past season and there have been a
big slaughter of cattle and other
outlets where this might have been used
because of the the prior droughts that
the nation suffered and so the supply
and demand I think was more responsible
for the price of corn falling and from
gasoline the prices falling because
fracking is competing and the feedstocks
for the gasoline are cheaper no I think
that's right I'm not I'm not an Ag
economist because of the Byzantine and
way agriculture is wrong I don't even
pretend what to be well on TV but I
think I think that's that's right the
there is a there is pressure to increase
the amount of ethanol and gasoline the
ethanol industry would love to be
mandated to go up to 15% blended into
the fuel with the result that they'd
like to make that other other 16 or 21
billion gallons of ethanol
conventionally with corn but the the
auto manufacturers are pushing back
against that one because it would
essentially kill any cars over like five
years old wouldn't be able handle it and
then the gas stations are screaming that
they'd be liable if the pumps were
labeled wrong or there was mixing in a
tank and so we've been spared the 15
percent expansion but I think I think
you're right but it's multiple forces
that would
that caused the the fluctuation of both
corn and and gasoline
my question was primarily answered thank
you
I'm psychic I'm not going anywhere
given the small concentration of co2 in
the atmosphere can you give a quick
explanation as to how this gas a trace
gas can be causing all of these
so-called problems how it can raise the
temperature as they claim it's going to
sure the question was given the very
very low composition of the atmosphere
that co2 represents how is it having it
the effect that the people predicting
warming say it does and the answer is
basically it's that you don't have to
have a very high concentration to retain
a bit of outgoing radiation from the
earth because if you do it over the
entire planet it adds up and the right
metals would come back and say well you
need a very low concentration of cyanide
to kill yourself you don't need very
high concentrations of the greenhouse
gases in fact you need even less of
methane because it's so much better at
blocking outgoing radiation so climate
change 101 right sunlight comes in it's
absorbed by the Earth's surface gets
reradiating
out to space as long wave radiation
infrared radiation you can't see we just
call it heat but the gases the
greenhouse gases hold it back because
the the molecules get excited when they
get struck by the radiation that and
they vibrate and that generates heat in
the atmosphere and because of the layer
of greenhouse gases the earth is warm
enough to be habitable without it it
wouldn't be and so it doesn't take a
huge amount extra or a huge amount to
have the effects they're talking about
as I said if you look at the actual data
and you look at the theory without
folding assumptions into it about
feedback prognostic mechanisms like
water vapor and like other like a growth
of of icy fields and things like that or
shrinkage of ice fields if you run those
if you run just a straight model of
physics you would expect to get one
degree centigrade one point to to be
centigrade of warming if you double the
concentration from the pre-industrial
level that was talked about earlier and
that's how that's climate 101 we have
time for one more question
if we have one more you mentioned dead
zones as being one of the consequences
of utilizing ethanol my question is is
it the sole cause and if not how largely
does it contribute to the problem
relative to other sources it's a very
large part of the it's a very large part
of the core of the cause it's not only
corn it's it's agriculture as a whole
but basically you know with when you
fertilized fields rain and what and and
watering mobilize the fertilizer and
eventually as all things do eventually
it runs to the rivers and from the
rivers it runs to the oceans and once
there fertilizes algae blooms and those
algae blooms consume all the oxygen that
would normally feed the fish so it's a
it's a general generic problem of
agriculture particularly but corn is is
particularly an intensive crop with
regard to the use of fertilizers you
have to use a lot of fertilizer to grow
corn and so now that's getting better
but of course the environmentalists are
fighting against the very kinds of
genetically modified corn that needs
less fertilizer but we're getting better
at using less fertilizer but still the
the coastal oceanic dead zones are quite
large as a result of agriculture in
general thank you thank you
yes the reception will be on the
mezzanine and students as a reminder
please use the stairway on the left
thank you very much